[Music]
kicked off its 43rd season ass with a
dream host of who's Ryan Gosling that is
you know if he ever gets into 30 rock
Ryan Gosling and jay-z opening the
season another saying like season 43
still going SuperDuper strong it'll be
wrong in second time hosting but now SNL
is live coast-to-coast and last time he
could barely get through his sketches
how did the aliens return you all to
earth
it's tough to keep a straight face
around this genius I've been called the
prophet I've been called a wizard called
a guru kate mckinnon is clowning around
on Vanity Fair's new cover celebrating
her Emmy win and alec baldwin's he's
back tomorrow for another season to have
him be so welcoming and so such a mentor
and a sweetheart was like with the
greatest thing of my life due to
scheduling Alex cameos will be kept to a
minimum but who won't we see Saturday
you don't ever want to leave something
that's amazing
Bobby Moynihan's out so our Vanessa
Bayer and sasheer zamata three new cast
members are in occluding the body of
alum Andy Samberg Chris ran and could we
also see some big stars maybe Queen be
supporting musical guest jay-z Ryan's
lady Ava Mendez has been seen inside 30
rock this week and what about Ben
Affleck been supported girlfriend and
SNL producer at Lindsay shook us at the
Emmy so we'll see and don't roll out
this lady pop it up at the Weekend
Update desk why is she the one for you
miss Scarlett Johansson
[Music]